my name is Eric Jones and I'll be your
moderator and at 12
have our groups break out into smaller
discussions and in groups of five so
immediately after this we'll break out
into into groups of five and so we're
going to have the presenters introduce
themselves okay we start with you to
introduce area I am today's a guardian
I've been adjunct professor in Colombia
for many many years I think I'm already
very familiar faces and that's my
teaching position so I think you know me
I'm catch a guru dos Santos and I'm the
deputy director in charge of client
services for the New York City
anti-violence project and I'm an adjunct
here at Columbia as well and class of 92
hi I'm colima d'souza I'm the
communications and outreach manager at
black woman's blueprint and in Angela
professor here at Columbia hmm hello my
name is Walter Vega um I'm see us SW
alum I was formerly the director of
advising here at cos SW and now I
currently I teach here the Social Work
practice with families course I'm on
faculty at the ackerman Institute for
the family and I'm with a small
nonprofit group New Destiny housing
overseeing a family support program I am
caridina house mr. bill I am I don't
hear i teach a theory and treatment of
suicide and i am a student like you i'm
finishing my doctorate degree at
washington university instant always my
research is around latino families and
children and mental health we just want
to thank you guys awaiting get started I
should have added that I am an alumni
also from Cornell doctorate program and
so thinking of you and having to talk
with privilege and power
I was thinking about what am I going to
tell you and the first thing to come to
my mind is how important is to be aware
of ourselves and how this awareness
keeps on changing as we were all this
and as we do different roles and
practices you know we are students and
that point very true some of you will be
practitioners in the field and right now
in the school you are students and so
you are very aware of some of the pros
and difficulties that you have among
yourselves with professors and in
general with the community of the School
of Social Work what I thought is that I
wanted to leave an example of one is a
very last experience I have of power and
privilege myself and this experience I
had about three or four days ago so it's
very fresh I have to go to an an office
of the AT&T cellular telephones and it
was a very big office and it repeated
some of the experience i also have as a
person in general well i went there and
of course there were a lot of people
still be seen but there was a front desk
with the person who you have to go first
as usual to say what why are you there
so i went there and that was a very
lovely very handsome person man behind
I sent that they sent it and he I
believe I don't know from where but he
was a black young man and I went to him
and it was my turn but he suddenly
jumped me and to connect space and the
next person was a man who again I don't
know where he comes from always have
difficulties knowing where are you but
he was a very handsome white man so
immediately reacted with that idea and I
said I was before the gentleman and the
gentleman behind me said yes absolutely
please come before me so he was very
lovely now the deliverer there in front
was not very happy with this because it
was obvious that he hugged me and he
know was not very cordial with me now
again perhaps I was feeling already my
own feelings of how I was reacting and
he immediately told me when I told him
what I wanted that I wanted to learn
more about the services APN tea etc
Chester and the contract etc when you
know we don't do any more than teaching
you have gotten to the Internet I don't
know as much needed nap as you do ladies
and gentlemen so I I said no I'm
terribly sorry but I cannot use us for
the questions I have it said that I want
to talk with somebody but he was not
willing to give me that so I immediately
use one of my obvious defense
that I said could you give me somebody
that speaks Spanish by the way I'm a
Latina epson maybe some of you don't
know that but I am a Latina so he sent
me to a very lovely Spanish woman which
of course we connected immediately
language wise color wise if every way so
she was lovely and I said this is what I
always do that's my defense I always
said I want to speak with us back with a
medieval Spanish okay so immediately we
very well and this is over we then you
have to sign this contract and of course
signing the contract filling forms she
said you have to have an identification
with your picture and that you have to
have you driver's license oh I said I'm
terribly sorry I don't have my driver's
license with me what can I do and she
says well we nearly driver's license i
said i have a big circle in my picture
which is very powerful I see Batman also
I had anything but I have all soaked the
Columbia University turned with my
picture and see really wanted to help me
but she didn't know how so she said you
know what I better go and ask this to my
supervisor so she went and lasted a
little longer so he right here it comes
to supervisor he was so impressed with
my Columbia card so that was the
privilege and the like list oh he wanted
to know who I do i do at Columbia
accepted etc so now I have the best
service and I said you know the lady who
was helping me who
I knew already hit name and we connected
very well I said she's helping me very
well so you don't need to take the time
no no no no no he wanted to help me with
that and he has ruled that I mean very
powerful you know so I thank him very
much he said can I have can I give him
my card I mean very powerful so look at
the different things that I experienced
this the sex difference the culture
difference the language difference most
important the power so i thought i
should share that with you and again
tell you that you have to be very self
aware of yourself especially in your
practice you know you can see i am the
oldest here i hope and i had quite a bit
an experience in several roles and i can
use it a lot of time telling you the
several experience i had both ways one
of me having the privilege and another
one not having me the privilege thank
you so much very lovely to win the
school and talking to you so now I'm
reconsidering that we let that as I go
first cuz i have to follow her um but I
will do my best the AT&T so it is really
great to be here and I was excited to be
part of this panel and I think I'm gonna
take my cue from today's
and talk about self-awareness a little
bit personally and as it intersects with
the professional excuse me so those of
you who have been in my classes I see a
few of you in the room well know that I
continue to talk about power privilege
and oppression some might say ad nauseam
I'm okay with that and i think what i
realize is i had a personal journey of
understanding my own power my own
privilege and how that intersected with
experiences of oppression that i have
experienced and continue to experience
and i think what you realize early on
with this self-awareness of which the
days i spoke is it's much easier to pay
attention to the places in which you've
been oppressed than the places in which
you hold power and privilege even those
those things intersect so it became
clear to me early on as an activist that
i was white was hard to realize that I'd
grown up in a community it was almost
entirely people of color and so when I
realized I was white and had white
privilege it took me a long time kind of
worked through that and figure out how
to own that and neither never forget it
for a minute even though our culture
would allow me to do that at a moment's
notice but realize what that bought me
in terms of power and privilege and what
my responsibility was as a white
activist and then social worker to be
conscious of the things that I got that
I didn't earn purely by the basis of
what I looked like I think it took me
longer to realize my class privilege I
actually grew up in a sort of a working
poor family but quickly realized that
associated with white privilege was
implied class privilege I passed a lot
and later when I in fact arrived in the
middle class the elusive middle class
that it was sort of assumed I'd always
been there right and that was all
related to my white privilege I knew
that I was queer when I was probably
about 14 or 15 years old I knew that
I was not limited to liking boys or
girls it was very confusing it was the
80s it was not easy trust me just trust
me and so I had a lot of oppression
based on sexual orientation both from my
straight friends who various of them
told me i was doing unnatural things and
from my gay friends who said like would
you just decide who you are for God's
eggs like don't be a poser right so I
had a lot of oppression about my sexual
orientation but again still had my white
privilege still had my class privilege
and realized over that times i began to
do more social justice work that i had
the privilege of speaking english as my
first language that i was a citizen when
i was working with undocumented folks
that was particularly clear to me how
I'd never thought about what that got me
and as i continue to do reproductive
health work worked in public hospitals
went to columbia university school
social work I realized also in doing
queer work and work within queer
communities that I had a lot of passing
privilege so fast forward a few decades
I married a guy total passing privileged
marriage privilege you name it but I
decided to be more open about my
identity experience a lot of homophobia
biphobia when I came out professionally
and I decided partly as a result of that
to go into working full time doing queer
anti-violence work that's what I wanted
to do and I found what I do that as very
very fortunate to work at abp where we
do work within abound violence within
and against LGBTQ and HIV affected
communities it was there that I learned
my most recently understood types of
privilege which was passing privilege a
really understanding what that meant for
folks with whom i twerked who don't have
any passing privilege my marriage
privilege and sort of my relationship
status privilege and my sis gender
privileged so my privilege on being a
cisgender woman and understand that
while I certainly had experienced tons
of sexism in my life that I had really
did not understand the depth to which
transphobia impact
our communities even for those who are
genderqueer gender non-conforming so at
each stage of me sort of understanding
my oppression I had to also look at
Associated power and privilege and
understand that impacted the work I do
the work that I do with my colleagues
and the work that I do with my clients
and at this point the work that I do in
coalition and in advocacy and
understanding as I teach my advocacy
students who are now in the room that I
have to understand my identity and what
how that plays into advocacy efforts in
which I'm involved right i bring my
privilege of my power to those spaces
and I like to think I use them for good
not evil but i'm still using them right
and that i can also use that power and
privilege sometimes to trump the
oppression so that if somebody wants to
be homophobic with me i can just talk
about you know i can speak from my
columbia place right and talk of it talk
from my power and privilege and and i
think the biggest and most difficult
lesson for me to learn in that was to
step back and speak less in order to not
take up so much space in places where i
have leadership some of which is due to
that unearned privilege and power and
that it is not my right or my place to
make space for anyone who has fewer
privileges than I do to speak but that
what i can do is not take up quite so
much space myself it's a subtle
difference but frankly it's really
pretty difficult to do I'm delighted to
be part of the New York City
anti-violence project we are currently
engaged in what is now about a two year
process of looking at the way in which
our organization is structured the way
that we do our work to make sure that we
are actually living anti-oppressive
values and that we could recognize
oppression as it manifests itself in our
work through our relationships with each
other and our policies procedures and
our trainings so I am committed to doing
that work for the rest of my life and
I'm really great too excited to be here
and talk about it with you
so it's hard to follow these two ladies
i will talk as a researcher and in
social work not as a clinician and the
experiences as a scholar and i will
share too personal examples and in
February we got money from the
Rockefeller Foundation which is a very
powerful organization talking about
powerful and privilege to go to
Dominican Republic to do research about
parenting and children outcomes I'm
white I'm latina I grew up in Argentina
and I immigrated to the United States
ten years ago with my accent so we
arrived together and that's how I went
to Dominican Republic with a group of
Latino researchers we had 10 a research
assistants starting their careers in
their masters and I was coordinating
this group and one of my first surprises
was that because in Argentina we don't
have african-americans or african south
americans or black people i have never
experienced what we see in America has
the differences between white and black
on the other hand I live in New York and
we share the public space and we are
completely mingles I have people from
every national and ethnic and racial
origin in my network so have never
experienced a class completely divided
even in the most segregated parts on the
United States we see interaction not so
in some parts of the Third Ward and not
son Dominican Republic which was my
first clear experience of power
separation and privilege based on race I
have never seen it before I've been in
Dominican Republic as a tourist but
never in the inner city collecting data
and it couldn't believe that in the
public schools everybody was black and
in the private schools everybody was
white and there was no separation there
was no mingling the barriers were so
clear so and also coming from America to
do research is a very powerful position
okay and we were paying ten dollars for
an interview that lasted 20 minutes so
in the private schools where people came
with drivers
and they were talking about parenting
through their Nana's which are the
nannies that take care of their children
we had a completely different experience
because I'm middle class in America and
they basically didn't accept the ten
dollars it was almost an insult and they
were telling us about their shopping
sprees in New York and everybody was
dressed in a different manner and
everybody was white and then we went to
the inner city slums which look very
different from our slums and there were
people that waited till 11pm making a
line in the school for the ten dollars
that we handed around ten in the morning
after waiting hours and hours in a line
and everybody was dark-skinned so I'm
sitting there doing as many interviews
as we could as fast as we can because we
knew these people were waiting for us
all night just for ten dollars how many
of us weighs ten dollars and nothing
every week and these people waited 10 12
14 hours for us to hand over ten dollars
so we were we felt very powerful and our
decision of ending the data collection
left a lot of people that waited long
for us without getting the ten dollars
so I'm sitting and doing this interview
and I was starting to get annoyed
because I have been four or five hours
without drinking water and asking the
same question that was kind of tired and
this lovely lady who had a couple of
kids and the kids were a little bit
misbehaving and you know I was a little
bit in title at that point that I wanted
to get out and I wanted to go and
refresh myself and get comfy we ended
the interview and there was a bridge in
moment and that's my point of this
example that we bridge understandings of
power and privilege constantly in her
work she asked me if she could touch my
skin because she had never interacted
with somebody who was as white as I am
and she had never felt how it felt to
touch a white skin and my jaw drop how
do you respond to that we are not
preparing our profession to deal with
those questions so I asked
in exchange for touching my skin if I
could touch her so it was a bridging
opportunity to both of us learn how to
interact with each other and also to
show that there's our skins felt the
same and we were two women doing her job
my job as a researcher and her job as a
subject and she volunteering and helping
me and I'm helping her pain so it was a
really gratifying experience at the end
that started in a way that it was a
little bit uncomfortable because at the
first moment I didn't know how to react
and that goes to your self-awareness so
I come back to the United States very
happy I'm very proud of our work and how
hard we work and I meet with a much more
senior experienced researcher who has
millions of dollars in grants and who
like I'm nothing next to that person
okay my work is meaningless and this
gentleman who is white doesn't have an
accent has incredible groans and
publications and I'm just starting and
I'm a junior scholar and I'm there to
try to gain experience and make a
connection I sit there not only he looks
at me and calls me sweetheart and I'm
not nobody's sweetheart and I cannot say
anything because I want to work with
this person then he starts to say about
his hesitation about working with
Latinos because Latinos are so
authoritarian Latino women don't speak
their mind and we are so
passive-aggressive and I'm just boiling
inside but I cannot say anything because
I'm deciding if i have to continue this
collaboration and let it grow because
it's very important for my career so
this point is not only we bridge
constantly notions of power and
privilege with others but also the
positions of power and privilege are
very fluid they're very plastic so our
own experiences our own understanding of
power privilege can change minute to
minute and in the Social Work profession
because we have so many hats and so many
roles you might be in an emergency room
a social working an emergency
and in in front of the client you are
very powerful because you're making
decisions about this charge about
calling ACS about treatment about who to
involve in the treatment and then you
talk with it attending the physician
that is in charge are you are not that
powerful the decisions the power is
transfer come you know immediately so
that awareness of where we are and what
is happening and how power and privilege
to contextualize is something that we
really need to become aware of and
bridges opportunities to reshape what we
think at what other think of us I really
appreciate everyone really speaking to
the the impact of intersectionality and
how contextualized power and privilege
really can be I always tell my classes
and folks I work with you know in in New
York i'm known as a man of color but in
Honduras where my family's from I'm know
I'm known as a gringo so it's
interesting just depending on where you
are what that all means so what I what I
want to do is just share with you a
little bit of some of what I've seen and
observed in the the field and I feel
that as with many of us here you know
I've worked in a variety of settings and
while the settings are very different
the dynamics are very much the same that
I see and one of those dynamics is that
in the social service world I mean we
are fighting for social justice but very
much we're working in a context even in
our agencies even in our direct practice
we're working in a context that reflects
very much the same world that we're
trying to change one of the things that
I think became so evident to me when I
first graduated as I worked in
preventive servant of services and I
just sort of looked around and I was
really going through my own
of self-awareness and identity and I
looked around at at just sort of the
organizational structure of the agencies
I would work for and it was fascinating
to me that you know while I think it's
certainly changing those in
administrative managerial positions by
and large was still white and those
frontline staff tended to be people of
color now you know when you think about
it and you think about how that's all
structured you know while I don't think
people would actually named it often
they would hire line workers to be
people of color well for lots of reasons
certainly social workers these social
workers would bring a lot of skill a lot
of potential to the field but I think
that something that goes unnamed often
is that these are Finn from the
perspective of administration these are
folks that can connect clients in a
particular way and that I found to be
both valuable but in some ways a little
exploitative if you know what I mean and
I think that that's something I've
struggled with a great deal because one
connection is very important but of
course when you're thought to be someone
to be able to connect with someone then
you're being limited in terms of your
identity it doesn't capture other parts
of who you are that may in fact not
connect with clients right off the bat
that make sense the folks so that's
something that I think you know I I
think it's something I learned right off
the bat immediately and I think I
struggled with for me being a man of
color the son of an immigrant being a
male and the privilege that came with
that and also being someone that
presented as white I think was really
important so when people said you know
kind of gave this sort of impression oh
you know your parents are immigrants and
you know you understand the immigrant
experience which to some extent I
certainly do certainly from the child's
perspective to some extent but you know
if I if you I were to have my mother
comes you know sit next to me on this
panel that you know you would say the
two
you look nothing alike my mother's very
dark skin as i am pretty much white and
the privilege that that's conferred on
that sort of i've been a game from that
is immense and so in my work that's
something I very much struggled with and
and and then on an organizational sort
of on an organizational perspective
that's something you notice and you try
to make sense out of and say like wow
this really kind of like in in a way
it's sort of the intention seem to be
good but it ends up as i experienced
them quite exploitative and I think in
I've one of the things I didn't mention
a partially on purpose is I also do
private practice and you know I've in my
time here as director of advising I
would speak to a host of students who
his dream was to be you know to go into
private practice and that was something
that you know they wanted to be a
psychotherapist and that was really
important and my question to them like I
would say that's great why did you come
to Social Work school to do that right
and often students would struggle with
that answer I said you could go to a
mental health counseling program right
you could do a psyd program you can go
to medical school and become a
psychiatrist but why social work school
and become a therapist and I think it's
because we often think of and I was just
talking to a student right now we want
to specialize our field so much that I
think in the effort to specialize it we
often lose sight of our roots in the
field and yes in clinical work clinical
work is about social justice work and
there are ways of doing that that I
think often don't get taught and
sometimes don't get taught not just in
the academic setting but I think also
once you leave the academic setting into
the professional world it's not taught
and their reasons for that I think so i
think that that's that's just another
thing that I observed both and in
becoming a clinician and the kind of
clinical work that I wanted to do and
the kind of clinical work I want to
teach so what have I learned and and
sort of some thoughts that I just want
to share with you about when you move on
to the professional
and in practice and again let me just
sort of reiterate that how I learned
this was as a man of color who presents
as white so there were some things that
i think i was able to do things that i
thought i think i was able to sort of
move forward that I definitely as some
people mentioned earlier my privilege
played a big role in it and being able
to move it forward hopefully you're all
familiar with the work of Paulo Freire
and hopefully and you know he he talked
a great deal about critical
consciousness and raising critical
consciousness he worked with workers in
Brazil to teach them how to read but he
didn't just teach them how to read he
also talked to them about why they why
it was they couldn't read in the first
place and I think that's a big part of
what it means for us to be social
workers is to engage in conversations
with our clients and our organizations
that say why is it why does the world
look like the way it does now and why is
there a need for us in the world and
engaging in those conversations a sort
of a bit of a hero of mine in the world
of family therapy Ken Hardy he he talks
about when working clinically with folks
with families in particular but you know
with anyone he says it's really
important to create breathing room in
your sessions in this space and what
does that mean it means you create space
for the sense of loss for the sense of
grief for the sense of anger and what's
often it for a sense of Rage that people
feel it's scary to sit with but you have
to create space for it that's what it
means to create the breathing room once
you're able to create that space a host
of opportunities can open up and I do
this with staff that I supervise I do
this with students in my class and I
urge them to do it with the folks they
work with with their clients and then
just sort of the last two things that I
want to leave you with is I think
supportive space
are incredibly important i think this
work can leave you sometimes feeling
very alone and in your agencies
hopefully you have the support to do
this I know it happens it's us SW but
it's important to create supportive
spaces along whatever lines supportive
spaces for women supportive spaces for
people identify as queer supportive
spaces for people of color what have you
but those supportive spaces have to be
there to create a forum for folks to
share experiences that they may not feel
there is an environment that welcomes
those experiences and then finally and
possibly the most challenging is how to
speak truth to power when you're in
agencies and you're a line worker or
even your middle management and you
realize that there are within your
agencies within your organization's ways
that are sort of repeating the
oppression that our clients experience
finding strategic ways to speak truth to
it because let's face it folks we got to
keep our jobs right and I just actually
spoke to a staff member of mine just
about what I was doing today and and she
said make sure to remind them that you
know I mean it absolutely we are you
know many of us consider ourselves
activists and we want to go out there
and change structures absolutely
sometimes you kind of have to stroke
power to speak truth to it sometimes you
have to strategically work within the
power system to speak truth to it how
you do that well maybe we'll offer a
class around that it may be this is that
you know that's the team taught
something here with this panel but um
but but that's that's really critical I
mean you can't go in there guns blazing
just right off the back is another thing
that can hardy says when he talks about
what are the tasks of subjugated people
he says you have to find effective ways
of channeling your rage it's critical to
do so I leave you with those thoughts
so I want to thank everyone on this on
this panel I'm anchor this panel and
ground it and i'm using everyone's
contribution to do that especially built
just building off of what Teresa Odessa
and Catherine and Walter said and then
using your example of being in a
different country as you know a white
skin privilege latina I think is what
what happened is conversation what
happened here was modeling some of the
things in with some of the ways in which
we can show up in the world and owned
our privilege and also want to invite
folks if you you know I'm quite sure
some things we said on this panel that
probably triggered you right like I'm
gonna say I was triggered right people
would trigger and it's okay and if you
need to take care of yourself take care
of yourself and also want to invite you
to challenge what what to bring it up to
speak to it right now so we can model
what this work actually looks like on
the ground rather in theory right this
is a space to do that I'm going to talk
about what does power and privilege do
what does that look like in terms of
allied ship what does it look like on
the ground because it's good for us to
have it here and even to have it here
but to have a hair like on the ground
like moving marching with folks on the
ground is totally different um and I
think that that's where we struggle even
the way in which we present ourselves
and even in which we identify ourselves
Catherine talked about always wanted to
identify with our subjugate ourselves
and Walter talked about the same thing
and I would encourage all of you to sort
of do a little bit of research around
Ken Hardy's task of the privilege and
task of the subjugated because it's
really easy for us to go to that space
of subjugation that's that space of
oppression rather than saying that i
also have privilege i am an afro latino
woman and i am clear that i'm afro
latina clear and I walk with a lot of
privilege and what does that mean when
I'm in a space with other people who may
not have that same kind of privilege
like Katherine I'm
queer proudly so right and that means
that I date men and I date women and
that any day and time if I feel like I
want to date a man or be in relationship
to a man that I am I know I'm walking
through the world with a lot of
privilege because society is gonna
accept me when I was walking through
42nd Street with my female partner my
woman partner this weekend someone came
up to us and said Jesus Saves and I
literally said yeah cuz he just saved
your ass I'm not gonna wait but it's a
very different reality you know as I'm
walking through with her and I'm saying
to myself we are unsafe and if you are
unsafe if I'm unsafe we are all Unsane
so how do i use my privilege to advance
on the ground not in theory on the
ground stuff for folks who don't have
access and I think that again like I say
that's what we struggle so one of the
things that I'm inviting folks to say
and to do in this work is to really do
an inventory of your privilege cell
where are you privilege we also talked
about I'm glad that he thought he said
that he's a laughing I'm Latino man
because him as a man he's walking
through this these hallways in this
school is so short that's probably
ninety percent women we're more power
than all of us a mass together let's be
real right he comes into this space
because he's a man he's doing this work
with more problems more power and
privilege and access and and people are
holding him up he's so great because
he's a man talking about sexism he
should be talking about sexism because
as men they perpetuate sexism right like
why does he get more power and privilege
than the rest of us because he's a man
in a ninety percent school of women
right so for him to own that is
revolutionary it is an example of what
it looks like to be an ally ship with
these four other women or identified
women
on this panel what does it look like for
Katherine to name the fact that she is
queer and that she is she's white with
privilege that ain't even to talk about
passing because we have to talk about
passing for us not to talk about passing
we are operating in alignment with the
same structures that put us in this
place in the first place right what else
can we do we can mount our resources so
if you have resources and you and true
allied where folks if that
resources access to free space to free
copies if you got creative stuff that
you can do if it's money deploy your
resources in support of folks who are on
the ground that do not necessarily have
access to those resources do not be
stingy and don't be confused maybe
sometimes folks for like I really want
to get involved I want to I want to
march what you all want to organize with
you but sometimes what we need is your
money right it's right sometimes what we
need is access to a free space so we
don't have to pay for it right sometimes
we need to design a flyer for free and
our website too because you have access
you have resources what can you do rick
ross did you hear about the requesting
hmm rick ross said he basically said you
can put a Molly and somebody in a
woman's drink and then take her home and
she'll enjoy it basically perpetuating
rape culture even when curve on Jan a
wireless was called a few white
feminists rose up in support or in
resistance to what is happening now they
tweeted but department with twitter is
that twitter is like it's here now and
it's gone tomorrow or having here now
and gone in two seconds right how do we
deploy our resources in a way that that
makes a lasting impression on the
institution's on the conversation so
rather than tweet how about you write a
piece in in support how about you be
vocal and visible and defiant in your
support for
people that you call yourselves being an
allied ship folks with privilege even
for me because I have privilege and I'm
gonna own that we like to be safe and I
say it you in order for you to be in
real allied ship you gotta be killed you
got to be so comfortable with being
unsafe that you live in perpetual fear
every day but you rise up anything you
say I dare you because you know that
you're not moving alone right these are
the things that I say in terms of power
and privilege don't have it just to have
it and then call yourself a social
worker or call yourself a good person
okay I don't don't do it use your power
and use your privilege to advance real
issues for real people at real time not
a 10 days later in the moment because
this work as social workers as real to
change agents is the real deal y'all
like when y'all leave these nice little
halls of Columbia is the real deal and
if I'm not safe I don't care how much
privilege you have you're not safe
because our liberation is interconnected
I want to take this time to thank our
panelists once again and we have we
still have some time left and I can feel
the energy in the room that there's a
lot of questions and that needs to be
asked it would like to be asked but I
would ask that you guys be mindful of
the time because we do have to shift
into a into a different panel after this
one so the podium in the stands here for
those that have a question and again
please be mindful of the of the time we
have ten minutes or so left hello i just
like to thank you discussion so I had
this this feeling over the weekend about
privilege I don't believe there in
person I go to school here I'm a veteran
so there's all these different things
that I get because of I think luck but
let me speak it real quick though
because because I come from a humble
background and my family has been humble
and you know I got out of situation
through what we call work and reading
and writing but when I go to different
venues I realized that that privileges
is nothing so my um my first experiences
when I drove down Church Avenue a couple
of weeks ago after kimani gray was
murdered that's what i'll call it and I
seen police cars all over the place I
seen horses and I seen young black kids
walking around and I'm driving down
Church Avenue and they say you
nigga what are you doing I'm like why
you mad at me because I didn't kill this
young man and I'm actually here feeling
really bad because if someone killed my
child and they put a whole bunch of
police officers in the neighborhood i
feel really bad i feel really weak I
think that they're bullying people that
look like me that easily I could have
been in that situation so I know that
that's something that could happen to me
easily I go to my fieldwork which is at
the fortune society and I see for
society and I sit in groups with these
young men who look just like me when I
was their age just like me and they tell
me that story about yeah
for this and I got in trouble for that
just like me and I was just able to
luckily escaped to the military and try
my hand at something else and when I
leave that room I feel really bad
because their stories end with what are
you going to do next and what's the next
plan and that's when I understand that
like that fake thing that I walk around
the school with that fake sense of
privilege and that's why I call it call
it fake because I I i also don't fit in
there's like five six seven of me that
look like me in this room they're not
that many black men in business in this
room rank but you know and it's always
the other thing about when I talked to
my brothers and we don't have the same
kind of goals and objectives so we fight
each other and we don't agree about
things so when I so where I'm going with
this is when you you have self-awareness
and you and you do know what's going on
and then you feel like when you sit in
front of the person who's supposed to be
your clinical directors but I don't
believe in cultural competency I believe
people that sit in front of me a
patient's not clients this isn't an out
client clinic cuz I outpatient clinic so
for me to voice myself I look like how I
feel because inside on my angry black
man and sometimes if you've been in
rooms with me you know I'm always saying
something because I'm frustrated so like
that privilege kind of gets stepped down
a little bit when someone says well yeah
he's just angry black man just talking
about things i'm not i'm bringing these
points up and i'm sorry i just want to
hear when you when you're sitting that
privilege and you sit in that room how
do you feel or how do you take that
anger down a little bit so it doesn't
come out as you know i angry black
person or an angry person which i'm
angry so yeah that's the truth thank you
I don't have I don't have a complete
answer to that but I have a piece that I
just want to address I don't know if the
goal is to take down the anger exactly
do you know what I mean I think that
there needs to be space for it do you
know what I mean I think there needs to
be a space for it and I think there
needs to be a space to talk about
exactly what that experience is is doing
to you do you know what I mean it i
think that and maybe you don't have that
space right now whether it's in class
whether it's in at your field placement
i don't know but i think creating and
that's what i was talking about earlier
that breathing room to be able to speak
to all parts of that experience because
it's III mean if I'm you know I sort of
have to like acknowledge this it's
interesting that you know I hear you
talking about that struggle and I'm
watching you in your Columbia gear yeah
at the same time so it's like I think
that's something that needs some space
needs to be made to kind of work you
know work work through that do you know
what I mean because I think that there
is some privilege there and and owning
that in and of itself might be it might
be a struggle so that just speaks a
piece of it if i can add something from
a clinical perspective anger has a
destructive connotation but also has a
constructive conversation the energy
that anger gives you allows you to
accomplish things and create so it's not
that angered has to be eliminated it has
to be directed in a way that allows you
to grow and own it and I shake something
positive what you are doing in your life
yeah okay so we have three more
questions and let's be mindful of the
time because we do have the transition
and before we take this next question
let's thank Teresa who's having to leave
for her
okay thank you first of all I'd like to
thank everybody who shared on the panel
today my question kind of stems from
what I was saying like okay in being a
social worker understanding that we're
doing like a lot of self-awareness and
trying to understand our privilege and
whatnot but my question is like going
off what he said like how do you
approach like maybe your bosses or the
supervisors or even professors when we
claim that you know we're trying to be
anti-oppressive but the very language
that we use when addressing you know the
people that we're working within our
communities and the way that we approach
working with these working with people
is very oppressive in and of itself and
I guess I'm nervous right now um like
how like how do you address that like
how do you approach that when it seems
as if like nobody in an organization may
be aware that what they're doing is
oppressive an extra my question um I'll
start but y'all should jump in so um I
think I think you hid it I think that's
the question is how do we do that I
think that as Walter said and as
Columbus that I think we have to do that
strategically so that if you're the only
person who notices that and you're a
student in your placement there is the
fact that you can't get fired because
you're a student in your placement but
you might want a reference so you have
to think about kind of your audience and
how something will be met I think that
we at the school have a responsibility
to engage in those conversations with
you and help you find a strategy and to
not leave oppression or structural
racism or structural classism intact and
and to try to deal with it so I think
it's important that you know it it's
important that you own it this is
troubling to you and you want to do
something about it and there should be
allies here at the school and the power
structure to help you with that I think
that it is
also we have to understand that I think
it is an ally ship as colima spoke to
that that's where things do get better
and as someone who's an aspiring a lie
around racial oppression I know that I
try really really hard to often be the
the person who is white who voices
something about racism and I really
appreciate it when somebody else who's
straight identified identify something
around sexual orientation or gender
identity right so I think it's important
to sort of build those allies because
none of us alone can fix this right so I
think it's about allied building I think
it's about identifying where are things
commit but if you're working for an
organization and certainly we know
they're out there where the whole
service model is oppressive I think it's
hard to know where to start and that's
more like you need to consult some folks
in and and work around it I know as a
professor in teaching advocacy I really
push and push and push and my students
would say yeah I pushed too much I want
them to analyze the impact that power
privilege and depression has have on the
issue as they define it the issue as it
is publicly defined the proposed
solution the way they analyze that and
the way they're going to go about it and
that I don't want just to understand how
racism impacts poverty and scat impacts
nutritional value in school lunches I
want to know how is that impacting the
way that that issue is talked about
framed addressed right so I think it's
about integrating never being done with
integrating this into the work that we
do I just want to encourage the thing
it's like when we wake up we wake up and
then we want everybody to be he'll be
awake with us right but we have to
remember that we are all socialized
under the same system we have had 12
years of racist sexist homophobic all
kind of stuff excuse my language so what
is you know that we've been socialized
systematically to believe and think
about ourselves and other people so when
we meet somebody ignorant you gotta meet
them right where they are because
they've had years of socialization and
so how do we chip away so even the fact
that you walk in and you
walk with your earrings and your natural
hair you are making a statement straight
up and down right like how do we how do
we make a statement in our spaces I have
Malcolm X on my walls you know like you
have you make a visible statement like
this is not to be tolerated I Know Who I
am and I know where I'm going and then
when you're having a conversation be
clear about what what is like what is
bothering you in a way that says I know
that you I'm gonna take I'm gonna take
that like give you the benefit of the
doubt I don't you don't mean to be
racist right now I'm going to let you
know that you are being racist right now
and then I'm going to invite you for a
further conversation and as students you
have process recordings that you could
light into stuff right in your papers in
your process recordings there's multiple
ways to be strategic and chip away at
the system you've got to figure out what
your spare of influences and activate it
in a lifeship in collaboration and
partnership with other folks in your
space and we have time so that's two
questions hi well you are already kind
of answering my question but I want a
little bit of an expansion my name is
Cassie a student white female middle
class heteronormative whole thing I will
identify as that I'm trying to I'm from
California as well and went really happy
for the opportunity to be in New York
and learning a whole sort of a more
information on how to go beyond just the
diversity and cultural competency
trainings I had so often and moving
really in tune anti-oppressive lens I
have been struggling this year as well
though I you know I went to undoing
racism training I've been part of suede
doing starting to really hopefully ramp
up to a second year of great work at the
school and in my placement and I'm
struggling with the information that I'm
now and the the knowledge and I'm
gaining with creating allies among
people that are white middle-class you
know non queer and how to have those
conversations because even outside the
school very much so but even inside the
school and
you know I'll get responses for friends
like well have you know has anyone else
tried to apply to UC because you know
white students are pushed out of the
University of California system or just
like little comments and I without after
the underrung racism training it was
really hard to come home and not like
start telling every white person that
they're racist and you know I had a
couple conversations that didn't end
well and so I kind of had to you know
and I'm finding ways but I don't know if
you can give any other way of how we're
talking about the systemic kind of
trauma that we all experience from being
raised in this country to trauma
stewardship I'll put a plug in for that
book I'm reading right now it's so good
i'm going to put it up on facebook page
and stuff and but how do we as white
allies create other white allies and
just yeah I just want to ask one
question are there any white anti-racist
organizers in the space right now these
are the people you should be talking to
go ahead and build community keep your
hands up so she can know this is serious
you guys didn't affinity group yeah you
need an affinity group because the thing
is people of color can't be the people
that's having those conversations with
white folks white folks who are
committed to undoing white supremacy
from within need to do the work with
other white folks right and so I I would
invite you today let me tell you
something I trust me I want to be an
allied ship with you right however I
want to I want you to have a community
so even when I'm not here that you
always have a community of people who
look like you who have your shared
experience to support your growth in
this movement and so I am encouraging
someone hand to start a white
anti-racist affinity yes yeah thank you
you go and she worried the caucus leader
and you get some work done right all
right
but I'm also hoping that everyone
understands at the school that it's okay
to house to have white spaces for people
to have those conversations let me that
it is critical it is it is critical and
I need to go to the day anti racist
white groups also citywide but that I if
I bring that into the space in Colombia
and other students that that will be
understood as well as part of the
struggle like yes and this whole
community will hold you accountable
waiting to doing that but this will be
our last question because we have the
breakout groups hate to the last clima
you said to be courageous and to speak
on something if it comes up so I'm doing
that right now and I knew I have a
thought that I need to be checked on I
need to just be confirmed with by the
community I've been thinking a lot about
this notion of privilege of men with in
social work and I'm thinking about how
much privilege I have walking around
these hallways and especially as a man
of color what that means and I'd like to
complicate it a little bit more because
i think that while i have male privilege
that are carried or wherever I go you
know where I like to the bank the line
of McDonald's doesn't matter I have it
um how much male privilege do I have
within a feminized profession how much
space do I have to be a male with in
this profession and is there an identity
of a male social worker for me to to
fill and I feel like I don't really have
a place to be a male in this in this
profession now it is true that I have
the advantage that because it is a
mostly female profession and because
oppression affects so many men of color
that I'd like you were saying people
assume that we're going to be able to
connect with men of color too and that
is very limiting like last year I didn't
get any female clients you know like I
did they would bring me kids and say
like oh he just needs a I think he needs
some like a father figure some mail time
I'm just like he needs to do his
homework
I'm not here for that so I think and if
at the same time I have seen myself be
the one who people praised for being
like analytical and like you parent
thank you for your being so organized
know stuff like that it happens yeah um
but this is this is an advantage that i
am that i have and my privilege is being
able to do to use it at ver at a very
low cost yeah because i can claim to be
i can use i can walk in like a man and
say this is the plan this is what we're
going to do XYZ blah blah blah and
people will listen because they expect
out of a man but like when as a
profession as a whole when i think about
is there a space for male social workers
I think we have a lot of work to do for
that and and a lot of that work is on us
men to come into the profession and like
be proud and brave about who we are and
say like this is how it should be but
there's also a lot of resistance there
and I feel it in class all the time
whenever had to bring up well you know
what about guys or the situation I we
learned about like domestic abuse all
the time and then in the situation I
never talked about I mean that hurts
both ways for women because the men are
the perpetrators but also there's no
program there's a dearth of programming
for men and whenever I bring it up I'm
like oh do I really wanna do this right
now is this like our people listening
and I haven't gotten the best reactions
so I guess it's like I don't know how to
handle my privilege in this setting and
I'm not sure how much if it is have an
advantage I know it do I have a
privilege in a feminized physician a
feminized world like I don't know and I
feel sometimes like I have to like elbow
my way into conversations and at the
same time I'm like learning a whole new
way of being because I can't be a guy
can't be like a man's man I mean I'm
gonna get thrown out the building for
that but I can I can't be I can't be a
woman not just not not to say that like
you know women are less or whatever but
I cannot be
me I have to be myself but but how do I
fit that into where I met so I guess I
just want to feel like I said I mean I
have just a just a short response to
that is I you know I think that's a
that's a individual process for how you
sort of want to carve that out and i
would definitely and i know the work
that the two of us have done together on
you know men of color supportive space
at the end of the day whatever it is you
have the privilege to make that space do
you know whatever it whatever the
outcome is you have the privilege to
make it because the fact is if we want
it to be a man's man i don't think we
would get thrown out of the building to
be honest we might get looked at you
know you might get looks you might get
not have a lot of friends but we could
if we wanted to and in fact in a lot of
the organization's I've worked in where
men are in charge they are very much
they they they almost like free license
now man it's like you know what I mean
and and so so I think that that's that
that space is available to us the space
that captures the complexities of what
it means to be a man is open to us if we
want to we just have to figure it out
and it's almost do you know what I mean
like I think that's just joining with
other men to kind of figure out what
that space is but whatever it is I think
we can take the privilege of making it I
just want to add something really quick
and I thank you for raising this I think
it's a really good question again I
think that that the the pivotal piece
here is that all of our power privilege
and oppression is intersectional and
that when you find yourself in a place
where the place where you're used to
having privilege is now not getting you
as much privilege which I talked about
with my my white students all the time
we're suddenly alike Oh perhaps it's not
so great that I'm white oh you know and
I'm mocking but I'm mocking would love
that I think I think that's the point
that's really difficult because it is
intersectional it you were exactly right
when you said this is really complicated
right so I think it's about as as Walter
said your own journey around those
things and as clima said to find an
allies to talk about it i also have been
in the field for over 20 years starting
when I was five um and I'm at
I'm i can tell you i have never seen a
guy graduate from the school would not
be able to find the job i have seen a
lot of gals to graduate in school and
have trouble finding a job because again
when you are a smaller proportion and
that may be what is deemed appropriately
or not as necessary for a job you got
less competition right so there's pros
there's cons it's all individually in
the opportunities um i would also say to
you so I I have been in anti-domestic
violence advocate for 30 years and I
spend most of my time with my sister
advocates in spaces where I talk about
the boys because we are where we were 30
years ago for men who experience
intimate partner violence right now
people don't ever don't think that
because you're a woman you're you're out
of this right men are abused by feminine
partners men are abused by male partners
men are abused by trans partners and you
know last year the report that my
organization did on intimate partner
violence United States over fifty
percent of the victims of murder were
men so there are places where once you
intersect something which is usually
around sexual orientation or gender
identity once you add the intersection
suddenly cradle to empower all in in the
ether and very complex so i think it's
continuing to do that inventory that
colima talked about and not losing sight
of where that privileges and that you
don't sort of get to count it some times
than not count other times in the same
way that you don't get to sort of ignore
your oppression right and to get allies
around us so thank you for raising it
yeah and i just wanna say one thing just
I'll be really quick because I love our
honey so he knows that um so you use a
couple of terms that i'm gonna have to
push back on you and we can continue
this conversation outside the feminized
profession we need to we need to define
that effort first of all what does that
mean because i know that we are
professionals predominantly women and we
put we started predominantly women I
don't know what it means to be feminized
that language is problematic because it
brings in a totally different
characteristics of so like the ideas of
what it does mean to be feminized right
that that's one yes the second thing is
when you're saying like to be a male and
there's this this this profession how
are you defining being a male what's
what's being a male you said like when
we come in and we do this and we do that
we do that that's being masculine that's
being male identified so in terms of
masculinity and it's sort of espousing
masculine traits of being and I'm not
sure that that's that is that that's who
we want to be like that's who you want
to be or like why are you I think how is
your identity sort of what is your
masculine identity in this profession is
probably some of the work that needs to
happen um and the third thing that I
want to say is that you know just
building off of what Catherine and
Walter said in terms of like this to a
personal journey I think it is also a
collective journey of understanding male
privilege and that everybody
irrespective of race has male privilege
um and how do you necessarily how do you
how do you hold on to that and hold on
to the other your other identities that
are not necessarily privileged in this
particular space so just like Catherine
said they're going to be many of us
that's not going to be able to find work
it's not gonna get the praise that you
get and I think you know all of that
even in the space i'm telling your
Heinie's even in the space and you've
got to be able to know for sure that
because just simply because you are a
male you get it and that's okay it's
just how you're going to use that
privilege to advance everything else
that you're an ally ship with you know
I'm so let's let's I i would love to
have this conversation about how you
identify like what is your definition
about being male and this is a question
all right no you and I like to ask
something I stopped because I I really
love you a question oh no laughs
irrational because you brought so many
interesting things to it and I think it
was very brave from you to come in
and I share with you because we have
been a tough set of your not giving you
feedback whatever so in order also to
change things we have two things in
relationship with others and I'm talking
with you in front of everybody but also
out of the room and there is a journal
of social work education and I think
your question is very valid and in our
profession we are not talking about that
but more and more men are coming into
our schools so there is a shift in the
culture of the school that has to take
place I know you encourage you to write
a letter to the editor not only because
that will amplify like this conversation
that we are having but also will help
you to think of what you are really
thinking going to your point and and
maybe start to move the conversation
that we need to have in our profession
about the things you are bringing an urn
education of social workers so just
thank you think I have them